we're gonna live says we're going live
all right I think we're live
I think we're live okay hello everyone
and welcome to round table with the
stream team where we talked to awesome
content creators and their journeys and
where they became where they became
today well you know what they've done
where they've been you know where
they're going and stuff like that so I
would like to welcome today to the round
table xbox four four eight how you doing
welcome
what is hey yeah what's going on how are
you yeah I'm doing good man it was a
busy Monday I just want to let you know
I have a bag full of secrets for my wife
Oh snaps I am spilling the beans tonight
on all of her secret information so it's
gonna be a good show man fantastic I'm
always down for secrets and little
little tidbits of information that
people wouldn't expect so are our other
table members are somewhere not coming
tonight somewhere
unfortunately old school got nailed with
an extra night week of work
unfortunately which makes us sad so
hopefully we can end up getting him and
next week and then we have MJ once again
College College gets him last-minute
every time so he exactly man I'm so
happy I'm done with that right now so
happy for yes he's he unfortunately had
to do one finalized report before before
we ended up you know being able to come
back and obey you should be coming
hopefully we can see it so book me where
are you
I think she's mad because I didn't
answer her message about the nightfall
and she might be boycotting right now I
don't know oh man I'm gonna have to I'll
find her I'm gonna text her five minutes
where are you is she is she is is
l-boogie playing destiny now snaps oh oh
man
she comes in we're gonna have to get her
name right now yeah I got it I gotta say
before
into anything how proud I am of osnaps
because she is like you know I told her
she's got to try destiny to when the new
content comes out you know when they
have um you know all year one is
free-to-play and of course because we we
share games from you know both of our
xbox ISM seek and she has chat yeah she
has shadow keep as well yeah and she has
come around brother I think I think
she's a guardian at heart and he is
digging the game right now yeah oh well
see I actually am going to reinstall
destiny because I I ended up stopped
playing right after Osiris because I I'm
a huge division 2 fan so I have to
actually I have to redownload it I have
to put I'm gonna plan on playing more
and I'm gonna I told cog was like hey oh
you guys are going to now be cross
saving and coming over to - you know PC
I'm like I think I've no excuse now
because I'm a PC gamer so that's just
that's just how it is oh yeah I know
that brother I I've done a little
research on this show and I've watched
and I hear you gushing over the PC yeah
yes yes but you know what I really love
what they're doing now with the consoles
and how they are you know making them
almost as good or better than PCs like I
know one buddy who actually just told me
he's like I'm actually thinking about
updating my computer because he has dual
780 s in his in his machine I'm like if
you don't wanna do a whole PC upgrade
you just buy an xbox for ps5 when it
comes out and since you know they cross
they've now put the cross play and
everything works for most games you know
it's gonna be good when when it comes to
pc and console and I know yo shout-out
to Brian Baker in the chat he is
definitely he goes back and forth
between PC and console and I know PC you
know you buy your graphics cards or CPUs
you know how much money you put into it
that's the power you get and stuff like
that but I feel like moving forward with
these consoles with them being
a closed platform and getting kind of
like unique hardware of course you know
you have to send a the Zen processor you
have the Navi GPU but the RD that goes
in on a closed platform like you know
when it comes to scarlet they're talking
about hardware accelerated rate racing I
think that's that's a unique thing that
I I know I know PC guys you buy the
power and stuff like that but I love to
see what like these developers do with
the closed platform the kind of the
customized Hardware you know what I'm
saying I can't you buy over the show I
know this is totally off topic but have
you ever thought that they could end up
making consoles kind of modular kind of
like dude just like literally pop out a
graphics card and pop in a new one
charge me 150 bucks instead of having to
for me to buy another like $400 console
because I will not buy that 400 all
console but if you tell me hey you want
to give me 150 bucks and I'll give you
this new GPU just plop right into your
xbox and I'll work I would do it dude
Phil Spencer he teased me like two years
ago yeah talking about possibly having a
modular Xbox so like when it came down
to I was actually a little over two
years ago because was before before the
ex was announced and everything like
that we we were hearing rumors and stuff
and I know me and shout out to the Don
as well another he's next podcast I'm
like family member because that's all
that's what we are we're just an
extended family but me and him we're
like I I was going on a limo I was like
yo dude I think they're gonna make it
modular you can just pull the piece out
upgraded you know graphics put put it in
and and stuff like that I wanted it to
go that way minute well what was it
about five years ago maybe Razer started
doing that with the laptops having those
enclosures with the GPUs in them so then
they can get better GPU usage out of it
I think that's why a lot of the modular
stuff came in I came into play
waylynn Alienware has like a fully
upgradeable gaming laptop now right
dad's I have not heard unn
ah dude I saw it it was um there was a
tech conference and they showed it uh it
was weird cuz the the back hinge part
kind of reminded me of a Lamborghini
with like hard angles and stuff like
that and they literally just just picked
up the keyboard and you can literally go
in and upgrade the hardware on it oh wow
the only bad thing about it in my
personal affinity it's Alienware that's
the only bad part the alien alien where
is super expensive but the only thing
that I kind of like about an alien
where's now are that they're being
they're being backed by Dell so at least
you know you're gonna have some good
warranties with it that's okay I proved
it I'm good with it
okay I'll give you the warranties man
yeah yeah all right now I'm back on
track
so I told you I'll just keep talking
brother hey two Italians getting
together you know we're gonna be talking
about stuff like this
yes Montalban a so all right so tell me
how you decided to why I should say why
you started to becoming a concert
creator why you wanted to become a
concert creator was there a specific
reason was there you know things mean
something you want to change is there
something you want to get your voice out
what why did you want to become a
content creator
well well first off the reason why I
wanted to do this like it started in
2013 I had my channel up like early 2014
and the thing was with with the release
of the new consoles if you remember back
in 2013
um Xbox went through a bunch of garbage
man there was a bunch of stuff they were
stepping on their own feet you know what
I'm saying they didn't know how to
explain what they were doing with their
system and because of that they're a
whole bunch of negativity just really
started like kind of like rolling
downhill
right right and um I was working that
game stopped at the time I picked up an
Xbox one you know I was playing the
games I was having a lot of fun I'm like
man
what is everybody's problem right now
like there's a lot you know with the
system to talk about there's a lot of
good stuff there you know for gamers
everything like that I'm like why is
everybody like hanging Xbox out to dry
now of course I do know about the higher
price point you know we're having Kinect
bundled into it now I don't stupid
I like the Kinect though I do like to
connect with them bundling it was they
should have given an option to bundle it
or not to bundle it and they only had
the bundles well see he didn't see this
is this again this is one of the reasons
why I started my channel because if if
people are listening to what Xbox was
saying the Kinect the original Kinect on
the 360 was really was really popular
one of the best-selling peripherals in
in video game industry like history
right mhm
oh but one of the things that developers
were coming back and saying when Xbox is
like hey why don't you put like Kinect
features in your game they're like well
not everybody that owns a 360 has a
Kinect
you know oh the way they thought about
kind of like curbing that whole thing
from the developers was well we're just
gonna put the Kinect in the box with all
the new Xbox ones yeah so like I can see
where they were coming from with that
right and and I thought if I put that
out there maybe other people be like
alright well that makes more sense now
you know what I'm saying yeah I really
like having the Kinect the you know I
really I really enjoy the fact of some
type of different type of way to control
what you're playing what you're doing so
I thought that was really really cool
and one of the other things I thought
was really interesting was finally when
like Mass Effect 3 came out and they
started having like the voice
communication portion of it so like if
you want if you told like Garris go here
you know was it called
oh my god I'm blanking like Rex go here
or whatever so that you can tell where
to go and what to do and then they would
do it which was awesome which I thought
was really cool but you could only do
that if you had to connect it with you
should have seen you should
seeing me and osnaps kids playing like
zoo tycoon and and putting up kind of
like there is like a mimic a mimic booth
and you put it up next to one of the one
of the animal cages or whatnot I put it
next to the chimpanzees and the kids
used to have fun they used to make like
you know faces and the chimpanzees used
to come up to the glass and mimic them
yeah dude it was absolutely amazing and
I'm like why are people harping on this
but but you know when I was thinking
about doing a channel and everything now
I was also thinking man I got to get an
elgato I got a captured game play and
stuff now with the new with at that time
the new consoles the ps4 and the Xbox
one they had their own kind of like DVR
software and you know and you know you
could put voiceovers and everything like
that and I'm like whoa what's stopping
me now I don't have to spend like the
$200 on a capture card and and learn how
to use some type of software on the
computer to do the voiceover and stuff
like that I can do it all from my system
yeah
and that's how I started man yeah so so
I guess you ended up starting that way
with through the Xbox and through you
just capturing all your your content
that way and then you did okay so what
was know so the reason you started your
channel then was because you wanted to
inform people of what was happening in
the gaming world that they didn't
understand the wake the way I say it the
way I say well my channel is I'm here
trying to put the common sense back into
gaming news mm-hmm because if you notice
especially the further and further we
got into this generation up to today
it's not just a video game thing it's a
society thing mm-hmm it seems like
people get put in the camps either all
on one side or all on the other right
all right so what I saw I saw a lot of
people kind of trashing Xbox that the
console that I'm playing and having a
last on and and and I also saw people
putting like PlayStation on a high
pedestal that couldn't be touched and
I'm like well I see issues over there
just like there are issues on Xbox
inside how come nobody's reporting that
as well right
Oh my whole goal was kind of like to be
there for the middleman
all right you know I I do prefer to play
on xbox I love the Xbox Live I love the
multiplayer aspect I do have a community
that you know I I've been on Xbox since
the original Xbox so you know I have a
bunch of friends that you know over the
years I've kind of built up you know a
friends list um but when it comes down
to it it wasn't all doom and gloom on
Xbox inside and it wasn't all sunshine
and rainbows on the other side so I
tried to be there for the people who
kind of looked a little more even-keeled
at the situation right and I wanted to
give them the gaming content in the
gaming news that I felt they deserve you
know yeah that's that makes a lot of
sense that's really that's a really good
way to do it and that's really I think
that your YouTube channel kind of
reflects that too I mean you have a
pretty interesting panel of people on
your podcasts on the next podcast do you
want to do want to to other talk about
that yeah definitely mention my I told
you before my life is an open book
yo huge huge shout out to the chat thank
you guys for showing up it's like you
think you know I'm just used to doing
this every time I'm live guys guys hit
that thumbs up button they'll share this
out on social media wherever you talk
yes they're going it is a deep die in 2
X 5 4 4 8 right now we're trying to go
as deep as possible
yo just just shout out to kognito I'm
not gonna I'm not gonna say he's like my
boss and III
them afterwards and I'm like I finished
the show did I do a good job are you
happy right Baker I figured okay please
continue
so it's so tell us about your your
podcast and you know what what other
interesting things you're doing well
well first off next podcast has been
running for a couple years now I think
like three years oh really
with you yeah and um shout out to my
brother Kay mega cuz uh Kay mega and Oh
snaps as well who's in the chat they
were the first couple people I started
talking to about doing a live show and I
I let him know I didn't want to do what
everybody else was doing at the time
having kind of like the hangouts and the
black background with icons and that's
it I'm like gamers want to see game play
as well mm-hmm
so I went into this and you can whenever
you talk to Kay mega you can ask him it
took months it took like for anywhere
between four months to like half a year
for me to get everything situated for
this show because I had to learn how to
use the open broadcast software oh yes
yeah yes I had to learn how to how the
format of the show was gonna be because
and I know I know other podcasts have
done game played before but we are a
part of a very our community which I
absolutely love our community but we got
to admit it's a it's a small part of a
worldwide gaming community right yeah
and and the community we're in I didn't
see anybody doing anything extra you
know everybody would just get together
black hangout talk about favorite
flowers and and yeah I was like man we
got to do something more than that
mm-hmm so we we came up with the idea to
do game play each panel member puts in
about 10 to 15 minutes a game play run
and we had we have that going wow we're
you know we're talking about whatever
topics went on throughout the week and
stuff like that
and and then not only that a little bit
later on we're like yeah well since
everybody's putting in game play why not
let the people who watch the show vote
for who had the best gameplay for the
episode and and um that's how it started
and when it came to like panel members
like I said I talked to Oh snaps and
came in right
I've known Kay mega since I was in
Facebook gaming groups talking about
gaming over there so I knew him for a
while really cool guy love talking games
with him so I I automatically knew he
was the first person outside of my
family that I talk I'm like dude you
gotta you gotta do this show come on
but what's it gonna take yeah okay um
but also with with bringing together the
panel one of my biggest things was I
knew people knew Kay mega just like they
knew me but I wanted to bring people in
that that had different personalities
that people never heard of before but
really had you know really had opinions
that they wanted to share was really
confident in sharing those opinions
about games and stuff like that
so we ended up with there was osnaps Kay
mega my brother Newark which he's
another guy that was with me throughout
like Facebook gaming groups and stuff
like that um we had somebody that we
called the golden voice and that was our
boy who skis because he he just had that
smooth voice when when when he talked
about stuff those [ __ ] tones like
Barry Manilow oh yeah yeah he was our
Barry and the funny thing was um with
playing Halo 5 I got a hold of this guy
named Don right mm-hmm
we call him the Don and turns out he's
an independent developer and we were
just playing Halo like I have over like
72 days in halo 5 multiplayer like in
game oh and yeah he was there for a lot
of it
we should go in and I was like Don
you're you know I would love to have
your kind of like your perspective on
the show as well being a developer right
I was like man that's something that you
know other shows out there don't have I
think you bring something unique to the
table that people are gonna want to hear
and the funny thing was Don was like
he's like yeah I'll make the show every
you know maybe once a month or something
like that
he ended up being for like two and a
half years and every any panel member
but that you know you just get that itch
once you start you know talking live
talking about gaming topics stuff like
that coming together with a bunch of
people that you trust that you can kind
of like flow with kind of wanna do it
every week right that bug so how many
how many panel members would you say you
have on the next podcast um anybody
who's been on the panel its own as a
family member so if if they ever want to
come back on and and you know just talk
about topics and stuff like that they
are more than welcome the DM for the
show is fairly big as of right now it is
me it is K mega is my brother predator
mm-hmm the newest member is crispy bomb
he's a huge gears guy like he is a gears
fanatic uh it was funny this past
Saturday we're talking about a
Playstation now yeah and how they cut
prices somehow he turned it into a gears
topic I have no idea how he did it
talking about PlayStation now and how
they they cut the price and stuff he
turned it into a gear stop it everyone's
got their own spin for it you know
specific things they're not passionate
about and they enjoy I definitely don't
wanna I don't want to go any further
without saying one of the most
opinionated youtubers that I have found
on the Internet
my brother knocks on this now he's not
able to show up like every week because
of his job and his work his schedule
changes on like a week-to-week basis but
this man talked about somebody who is
passionate about gaming and it is not
Freight not afraid to share his opinion
no matter how many people would like it
huh or how many people would hate it
like he's just gonna put it out there
he's from he's from
he's from the rotten apple he's from NYC
so like I said there's no there's no
thorough filthy you know what yeah
that's what that's what happens so I
just wanted to I just want to say hello
l-boogie hurry up it's fine it's fine I
figured you you know you were in the
process of changing your schedule and
everything so yeah you're still a West
Coast time how are you everything good
happy happy to see you here I'm happy
I'm happy you're here and I'm happy that
you were able to connect me to 2x
perfect boogie boogie I told the miles
like dude like I once I start talking I
don't shut up you know this boogie yeah
tell me whirring okay so tell me because
she sent me a message on Xbox she's like
I am he looking for you and I'm like
what
are you talking about okay you'll see
afterwards we didn't go we didn't go
that bad thanks I appreciate it even
even Brian Baker he was like is that
boogie like you just made him so excited
right now in the chest
we were just we're going over you know
the podcast and and you know how many
people he has on with him and and you
know what type of you know what type of
other things he does other than other
than the podcast every week well I don't
get what because I won because I won
this past week how about all men times a
mega one predator one only person who
never won is is my brother
the angry otter dark Adonis autumn is
has not won a single game play poll yet
that says I feel for him I really do but
he said he's going for the street like
when we do gameplay cuz now yeah we've
curbed it down to once a month we don't
we do a gameplay episode once a month
because man it's just it's hard getting
everybody to to put in game play every
week and like that you know like though
that's pretty awesome and engaging
further people who watch the you know
thank you I appreciate that we got a fan
nice so when when you with all the
you your co-anchors if you will how did
you find your co-anchors to make sure
that you had compatible Quebecers to
work with what your mentality and your
thought process was um that's a great
question
uh first off I try to get different
personalities I I definitely want like I
like the loud outgoing people but even
you know the people who are quieter more
even tone a lot of times have a lot of
stuff say um thank you really you know
can really put a lot into a conversation
about like gaming news and their ideas
and stuff usually I will go through
YouTube and I will see like I will check
out different youtubers and stuff like
that um you know people posting on
Twitter about their channels and they're
like I'm a small channel looking to grow
talk gaming news and stuff I will check
all that stuff out and um the next thing
I do is I you know I I add them to my
friends list on xbox and and we gamed
again that that's that's another thing
you know and and we see how we kind of
like jive like if you know if everything
is cool like if we if we can game and
talk and just kind of like BS and stuff
like that in in an Xbox Live party chat
my next step is like out then you want
it to a show some Saturday or something
like that and then from there um I just
try to get them to come on every single
Saturday yeah yeah editor that yeah Adam
to the Facebook message Europe and you
just go from there yeah I will say a
couple people who was a little bit
different like dark autumn mist and
predator predator I have been a fan of
predator ever since I saw him on the
shop podcast shout-out to ptk blam if
you guys don't know he is another
podcast that it's on Saturday nights you
guys gotta check out he actually hit
up today on on our on our pages on our
Twitter and on on my on my Twitter
directly and I was actually talking to
him today actually believe it or not I
didn't believe it or not podcasts for me
to be part of like this is kind of new
I've been working kind of like I always
say I'm like us I'm always behind the
the behind the curtain I do a lot of
stuff for ILP but people wouldn't know
that so when I came up to kognito and I
said hey I think this would be good and
I said I want a one l-boogie
I want old school I want MJ I'm like
these are the these are the people that
I know that I've been working with for
for almost a year - in streaming stuff
and be able to do something like this so
when he kind of introduced himself to me
and we were talking about and forth I
was like right this guy seems pretty
cool and I'm like I'm gonna have to get
him on and and when Elba he introduced
me to you because she's more into the
the podcasting realm than I am I checked
your information out I was like all
right this guy's cool I'm like this is
good this is gonna be good this is gonna
be fun
but yes anyway sorry continue I just
thought you'd want that little little
tidbit of information
[Music]
snaps asleep on the couch because you
know you don't know you got to get her
on some time and well first off I
appreciate that l-boogie yeah what I
mean I've been around for a while like
people even realized I've been on like
you know I do cross fire with the mooch
every Friday I am now on Xbox nation if
you can call it Xbox nation now like
every Wednesday they say is they even
though he hangs out with some people
that are question he's himself
upstanding well yeah that's
there's a couple reasons why I'm still
on those shows first off these people
are my friends I'm a very loyal person
like you get you get into my inner
circles there is just about yeah I'll do
just about anything you need me to do
right uh second of all I feel like I
bring a more level-headed opinion when
it comes to codes like that you know
people tell me all the time all you
should leave the show or you why are you
still on that show it's like well
because I feel like you're stirs people
who watch that show that can actually
benefit from a more level-headed opinion
of what's going on you know I'm not I'm
not the type of person that just because
um maybe parameters change or it's not
the second show that it used to be I'm
not just gonna like take my ball and go
home you know I'm there I'm there for
the people that watch so you you've you
essentially feel like you have to be the
rock you have to be the one that brings
the insanity to a normalized level you
have to be like the people's word yes
all right if you notice like you even
see um I have my icon down right I know
necessarily I don't do webcam and stuff
like that because when and this is just
something that with thinking about my
channel and kind of like how I want
people to think about me I want people
to think about like Xbox or for eight as
like that inner voice gamer inside that
like they don't they don't like
necessarily I've shared pictures on
Twitter people know what I look like
stuff like that but when when you're
listening about it and again trying to
bring that common sense back into it I
want people to feel like they're like
inner gamer is talking at that point in
time that's pretty much why I do that
your inner coast if you will
yeah yeah oh you're gonna bring it back
to d2 yeah I saw I saw about the strike
I'm sorry I didn't I try in each or I
was first I'm neutral but I will say the
first words out of his mouth was
l-boogie I have to apologize I don't
there's the first word she said nine ten
so we can go and we can die together
it's the well it's the the new strike
and the first time I was in the new
strike that was insane
that was absolutely insane if you notice
there are more NPCs coming at you than
any other iteration of destiny - they're
all over the place we'll have you doing
me like vex crazy oh yeah yeah oh that's
so much more gear so you just have like
wave upon wave like enemies just coming
in like I don't even know where I'm
shooting I'm just shooting yeah you just
never everybody turn around you just see
a red lens it is so much fun right now
I'm having now can you play destiny no I
was actually telling X bot about this
earlier since a lot of the guys are
talking about going back to PC because
they can move their saves I told them
that I'm actually gonna reinstall and
I'm gonna try to get I actually never
moved my save from from Activision over
I hope I still okay yeah so I'm gonna
pull my save over and then I'm gonna be
able to play I'm gonna update the shadow
key but I'm gonna end up you know
probably playing if if when I have time
cuz like you know for me it's it's
always a time restraint question better
watch out for those sweaty hand cannons
all right there's no kickback whatsoever
so I will tell you that once once I
started PC gaming and
doing first-person shooters and
third-person shooters on PC that there
there's almost no way I tried
when Division two came out I got a copy
for PC and I got a copy for Xbox and I
played Xbox twice and I did that with
Division one and I did it with division
two and I do something with the controls
I just I can't I just can't deal with it
so I'd rather I'd rather stick with the
PC so it's funny you say that because
people try to say that with third-person
shooters
there's not really that much difference
between one controller and I'm like all
of it I'm sorry I feel like it's I feel
like it's no no offense the console
players I feel like it's really cheap
that I can take my camera right and put
it like off-center like this and it
snaps to the middle I'm like how is that
even right like that's like that's just
the aim-assist on you know the targeting
and I'm like that just doesn't feel
right to me but that's like I said
that's just me because I'm so used to
playing on PC for so long I love the
disclaimer before so I'm not trying not
to make anybody angry it's just what I
am are you are you planning on going to
any conventions or anything this area um
I want to try to make it to e3 that that
is that is a goal of mine um a lot of
people got to go last year and they were
asked
I actually I got a ticket for the Xbox
show over the fan fest and everything
like that like you know sign-in got
ticking I'm like you know when it comes
down to it
I I didn't think they were gonna go all
out
mm-hmm this past e3 but whenever there
is new hardware logic and there's a
warmth lineup for that new hardware and
it's a significant step up it comes to
power and everything like that that's
what you really if if you haven't gone
to something like III that's when you
really want to go run because that's
everything is over
top the volumes up to 12 and and I
really want to go this year really want
to go yeah that's from from a lot of the
past panel members that we've had that
have been on they they're saying the
same thing they feel like next year is
going to be an e3 year it is going to be
the best option for conventions to go to
so it's going to be really interesting
to see how they're gonna be low man
they're gonna be showing halo oh oh
that's gonna happen
I mean we're gonna know when the actual
Xbox five or whatever anaconda whatever
you want to call it is coming out PS
five when that thing comes out you know
what's good all those things were
actually gonna get some dates so and we
it was actually funny because we
actually spoke about that on ILP and I
said and a lot of the other guys are
saying 2020 we're gonna see it in 2020
end of 2020 at mid 2020 and it's gonna
be really nice to see it actually in its
entirety and what it's actually gonna
look like and it's gonna it's gonna be
great in III I think is gonna be the
show to beat that next year it's gonna
be really really good
Oh another reason why I didn't
necessarily want to go last year is
because Sony was they were in my ear
yep yeah you think are gonna be in my
this coming year now oh they're gonna be
they're really telling because like
people it didn't matter what I say
people already believe that arm like
this
Xbox cult member member or whatever I
was there for your initiation right like
that is that was such a [ __ ] defense
that was like we do not care about we
just want your money
oh yeah that is their mantra
like Sony does not care about what you
guys want they're gonna give me the bare
minimum to keep you purchasing but other
than that they don't care and this is
what I said like when it comes down to
it and I know there's there's other
conferences throughout the year but for
lack of a better term III is like the
mecca for like all gaming yeah you know
like you want to go there and you want
to check out you know what Sony has to
offer in their conference you want to
see what Xbox is doing Nintendo does
their treehouse but they are also on the
floor right big time 93 as well and then
of course now you have PC gaming because
the more and more we get into it and the
more and more that AMD is developing
their hardware the cheaper and cheaper
it is for gaming rigs for you to like
really get a decent rig and it doesn't
cost an arm and a leg like it did a
couple years ago you know yeah so you
have the PC gaming space as well it's
where all gamers go and and just talk
about games and look at what's new and
stuff like that so it was really it was
it was really kind of like a heartbreak
that like Sony is just like and now
we're we're good well scary yeah you
know I think to show like I'm really you
don't because I'm pretty sure you could
come up with something but they don't
because they would be they would have
been showing you their stranding trailer
that we've already seen oh why you speak
of that poopy game what story I was just
gonna ask that well I agree what's there
I will I will do what I do on every game
I question I will watch a streamer play
for the first couple of hours and go oh
that's the plot no I'm not gonna buy it
that's what I will I will I will be on
your stream you you put you know I got
into it so you never know I think that
some of the things he does is like super
weird but you know I'm still gonna try
it out
full game even though he reminds me of
the character from Grandma's Boy oh man
you got me choking on my babe right now
bring out in robot voice be like how did
he see me I love that movie oh my
goodness
Oh what do you think we're gonna see at
the game Awards coming up here is
anything new or like I have no idea to
be really honest with you especially
like you know we're going into a year
where new hardware and stuff like that
is coming out and and from what I've
seen from like at least on the the Sony
and and the Microsoft side of things is
they are keeping things very kind of
like tight-lipped right now like and I
don't know what we would see from the
game Awards I mean I'm gonna watch it
and see what you know what what they
show but I I cannot I cannot make a
prediction right now I don't know I I
haven't I I honestly haven't seen any
words in a while like since they were on
g4 yeah pretty much pretty much
g---forty small funny story my parents
said hey Pete we're gonna change our
cable and I said you can get whatever
you want
just make sure g4 TV stays on TV come
work watch attack of the show and chill
and relax that's pretty much what I told
my parents well boogies what do you
think like what do you think is gonna be
shown it's the end of the cycle so I
think we're gonna really see anything
new anymore
maybe maybe some hold on hold on wait
for it battle oh my god we know it's we
know it's here I will I will say people
have a disdain for the game I think it
looks
great like I love like the Saturday
morning do you want to know what's
amazing
do you play streets of rage oh yeah okay
PAX East
I literally play streets of rage four
five whichever the new one new one right
the new hasn't been released we we could
not even videotape it but I will tell
you I will tell you this so good oh yeah
so good it literally like I'm getting
goosebumps thinking about how good it
was I think it's to reach poor if I
remember I beat all three of them so
quick story when we went and played I
played with MJ and kognito was sitting
to the left of me talking to the dev and
MJ never played that type of game before
oh wow but whoops whoops within the
first I don't know 10 minutes and you
tell them that you have to go up and
down to go like yeah move around oh I I
look at the COG and I was like how far
do you want me to go with this and he's
like finish it and I was like okay game
faced it I finished it the whole thing
and the devs were just sitting there
going are you serious right now
like as I sat there for like 30 minutes
and I just did like all those old-school
tactics like you know how you can like
jump left and then kick and then jump or
what like back to the other way and kick
and you like stay out of the range of
the guy I was doing all of that stuff I
was doing all the old-school moves and
these people are just like I like I used
to be god I was just like I used to I
used to like be in the enemy it's going
up like you're I'd go up to the top
right and all the enemies would come up
and then you would go down a little bit
and then like just start punching and as
they're coming down they're coming right
into your punches setting up for the
combos that way and you get like three
or four guys just don't do like getting
knocked back and he's going with the
combos like and going with the uppercut
and stuff like that that's the way I use
clay I guess I guess the devs didn't
realized that like I knew all the old
tactics like
grab the guy I need him twice then I'd
flip over him twice and grab him again
and they'd kick him again and need him
again and the guys are like what we
didn't old school
you got old school it was fantastic it's
fantastic looks good well I I mean them
coming out with the new shoots rage
that's gonna be awesome and you know I
know
a lot of people out there like they'll
talk kind of like negative about like
the new battle zones but from what I see
they've taken like that combo system
from Battletoads
and they they they cranked it up a notch
they definitely the reason why people
are so anxious with Battletoads is
because their PTSD from the from the
zoom stage value why that is why most
people are probably like nervous to play
it I think it's gonna be great and I
think they're gonna fix a lot of those
things because technology's so much
different because when they when did
that game come out 88 89 I want to say
like 87 88 yeah it's a long time ago but
I remember when I gotta get that I gotta
get that I waited so long game did you
ever beat it no no no no no and you want
to know what if you did get to the end
boss it was so wonky that most people
couldn't even beat it I really now I
will now see it beaten because people do
it in games done quick the only reason
why I've seen it was see in the end or
it seen okay so it's game it's a game
that definitely deserves kind of like
that remaster because of stuff that
happened back in the day when you know
gaming was was younger I guess and had
more issues and stuff like that what the
whippersnapper effect yep yeah it's like
what build us old fogies they know other
games were back in the day it would the
first game I ever played was on the
Atari it was involved that was my first
favorite game was pitfall and and I
thought I thought I was a genius because
I'm the one who figured out to stand on
the alligators eyes and and kind of
your time jumping on the alligator's
head as long as you stay on their eyes
you don't get eaten I thought I was a
genius at that point I'm all my other
cousins we're falling to their death
with everything I'm like ah that's all
you got to do right here you didn't know
that the eyes yeah get them in the eyes
ah man but that's when that's that's
when I knew I was gonna be a gamer just
like movies man
so so you do you do the podcast I do the
YouTube channel what what else do you
what else do you do what else do you
stream also well I stream on my youtube
channel as well mm-hmm every once in a
while I'll do mixer I've been trying to
find a way to incorporate mixer into it
and I all honesty because it's
integrated into my xbox and it makes it
really easy to just go live mm-hmm like
I'm thinking about making like my mixer
um kind of like the B side of my gaming
you know Oh games that don't necessarily
you know people better a little more
niche like I play um pro golf club 20:19
absolutely love that game
yeah and and it's a game that you know
not everybody that follows me wants to
watch but it I like stream that I mix it
or something like that so this way
people get kind of like the complete
idea of of me as a gamer you know you'll
see you'll see the halos and the
Destiny's and stuff like that on my
youtube channel right but and you come
over here come over to mixer and you'll
you'll see Max and Max in the curse of
brotherhood and you'll see you know you
know the golf club 2019 stuff like that
stuff that uh just shown me as a
complete game like all the way around
and I think that's where I'm going with
mixer but other than that like I do most
of my stuff on YouTube because and I see
a lot of content creators like alright
I'm live now here on Twitch and then
they drop a video over here are you
- and then all of a sudden they're over
here doing this and they're over there
doing that like I'm not I'm not
big-headed enough to be like yeah you
should follow me over here and then
follow me over there and then like I try
to put my content all in one place where
people people know where I am and where
and where they can go and check it out
that's why I think I think the reason
why a lot of people do that with twitch
at least is because when you stream on
Twitch you can actually just go in there
highlight what you want export it and
then dump it over on YouTube super easy
so that way people can do both like that
way they can have both done really easy
but I mean I agree I kind of agree with
you I mean to be able to split your kind
of viewer base I've always thought it
was kind of weird like I know that a
couple of other people and old-school of
the podcast he does that too because he
has said that he has a couple of people
that cross pollinate from one from one
platform to another so it's really
interesting to hear that you you know
you would like to do you like to do that
they did but it makes sense how you're
saying it because you want that other
type of group of people to be on that
side yeah yeah and like when it comes to
the mixer it's just an option to see
stuff that that doesn't normally get get
streamed but I play like if you if you
ever check out my my my xbox live
account you'll go in and check it out
you'll see I play a ton of different
games mm-hmm and I can't like I I can't
put it all on you to you know I'm like
you know III think I'll make like mix
are kind of like the B side of me you
know what I'm saying and possibly with
mixer and not having like music
copyright and stuff like that I can I
can play like golf with Spotify on with
one of my playlists going and stuff like
that there's a little more freedom there
where you know what YouTube like if they
get a little hint of a song that you
know a popular artist created or
something like that your
your videos Gohan right yeah we had we
actually had respond TV who's a twitch
streamer last week and he his thing is
playing the Gazoo like that's his that's
his his schtick if you will
I like that and you want to know what he
actually has gotten hit with copyright
for playing the kazoo
he actually had something called the
pink kazoo which is the Pink Panther
with a kazoo and he actually got nailed
with copyright because it sounded
exactly like the regular pink Panther's
so yeah so it's very very finicky on
what you know could be grabbed on what
couldn't be grabbed yeah I mean let's
let's be honest here and I'm not saying
everybody and stuff like that but I know
a lot of people go to twitch to stream
because it's the most popular platform
for streaming
they're you know they're people that you
know they want to succeed they want to
become popular they you know they they
want to become partnered they want to
you know make this a career mm-hmm and
stuff like that and for those people you
know going over to twitch and you know I
can definitely see that me I have the
entire time I started my my youtube
channel cuz I've seen people come I've
seen people go I've seen youtubers
change I've seen streamers change and
everything like that and I always kept
it in back of my head to always be the
same person and I've had people ask me
about like monetization and stuff like
that and it's like well I would love I
would love to make enough on YouTube so
that would equal out to a 40-hour a week
job yeah all right I would love to do
that that would be amazing that would
mean there would be so much more freedom
I can you know put just so much more
content into it because I wouldn't
necessarily have to work my job and
stuff like that but I don't make it a
top priority my top priority is is to
always stay attached as a gamer and out
of business man yeah you see what I'm
saying yeah you gaming first money later
yeah yes yeah that's that's one thing I
like I said I've been around for a few
years um and I've gotten in an
incredible community of people who watch
my content and everything like that I
haven't blown up like other people have
around me and and to me that that's all
good because like at the end of the day
it's not my main priority to do so but
if I can if I can do so while keeping my
gaming integrity that would be the
ultimate success for my channel in my
opinion yeah I don't think I will go as
far as IQ what I always say is that when
people that are content creators like
all of us being hitting it big is like
hitting the lotto
it's literally hitting the lotto being
in the right place at the right time
saying the right thing with the right
conversation it is the lotto and it's
it's very hard to want to have anyone to
do that but if when you do it the lotto
it's like you hit it big and then you go
from once that was one spectrum all the
way to the other like I see people that
are the full-time content creators and
they think oh I can just do this for
eight hours a day and then they start
almost like they become addicted to it
and then they start going nine hours ten
hours twelve they in a lot of those
people that I end up seeing and do those
large amounts of time frame they have no
work personal life balance anymore so
it's like one of those things you have
to be really really careful little
careful of when when you do hit it big
and that's what that's all these people
that come on onto this podcast I want
them to hit it big I want them to be
successful I want them to be able to do
what their dreams are that's that's why
I think that you know
this this is great and that's what
that's what I hope free for you you know
I want you to be able to do that I
appreciate that man and I like I said
the that's the one thing that's that's
been consistent in my whole YouTube
thing is like I always I always stay
attached to the gamer mm-hmm - you know
I I love games now the way I love them
when I like was 12 years old you don't
I'm saying which which has me getting
excited for a game like Battletoads
where the rest of the community is
telling me you're freaking crazy what
the hell are you talking about like why
why do you want to play that and I'm
like well because it looks like fun oh
yeah it doesn't it doesn't have to be
this heavy emotional like story driven
narrative third-person view like my all
my games don't have to be that way on
the 360 one of the games I play the most
was a game called Fancy Pants Adventures
I don't know if you know about that game
I do not
dude it's like a stick figure literally
a stick figure running through this
world
it looks like a kid drew the world all
right
but with running and you're running down
a hill that they have a momentum like a
momentum engine in this that is
completely addicted but you couldn't as
you're running down the hill you're
gaining steam and you go up to like
running up the hill and you jump you fly
you literally fly and it is so much fun
dude I couldn't even tell you what the
hell is going on with the story
my bad for the 80 double hockey stick
but most I couldn't tell you what was
going on in the story but just playing
that game and like they call it fancy
pants so like as you progress you unlock
all these like really funky like shorts
and and is that your stick figure can
wear while they're running around it was
like one of the stupidest games but I
had an absolute blast and that that
right there that feeling and that energy
like if I loot if I ever lose that I
will get off of youtube like this and
it's it's done it's done I I turned
corporate and I don't want to do that
alright so how has your your YouTube
channel and your passion for games
really affected you know your your
family life our who is it like
supportive is it the kind of like molded
into something better
how is that for you well um
you know I I will say at first when I
first started it was probably it was a
little rough
people people around me including like
my mom my sister didn't necessarily
understand why I was doing that didn't
understand understand when I'm like oh
this news just dropped yeah I gotta make
a video about this like right now and
there's like oh okay they didn't really
understand what I was doing um uh within
this whole thing and getting together
with my wife now I have been absolutely
blessed because when you look at my
family um I'm a gamer I'm a youtuber I
do podcasts
um my wife she is a gamer she is a
streamer and she has her own gaming
podcast uh you look at the kids the kids
um they're all gamers my my 16 year old
when it comes to destiny - I think he's
about to hit like 930 power level in
that game uh he's trying he tried to do
the 24 hour raid balance when the raid
came out first um our 11 year old twins
which I try to regulate it a little bit
more with them because if if I oh if Nia
no snaps allow it they wouldn't go
outside they wouldn't they ain't not
with anybody also dislike just like the
meme hey kids go play outside and there
they have the TV in the window for sure
dad don't worry about us we're good
we're playing outside
they'll play fort night in roblox right
yes
roadblock she's watching people play
robot yes oh my goodness yes but
thankfully thankfully we we move to a
different part of Connecticut and now we
are we're like five minutes away from
the beach we we have like this there's
this entire like apartment complex that
were a part of there's there's kids
running outside and now the 11 year olds
are going outside to ride their bikes
more one of them is one of them is going
out to hang with this girl called Emma
you know so I I think the move was was
really good for them because we were
where we were living before that um it
wasn't the greatest neighborhood I did
not trust the kids out there like the
kids were like they were out like
stealing people's mail and there was
throw is like 12 13 year olds out at
like 2:00 3:00 in the morning hanging
out on the street and I'm like nah man
we got a date they could have friends
over in their yard and our yard was
really small as well but I wouldn't like
me and osnaps we definitely agreed like
they're not going to hang out with these
kids on the street and stuff like that
so at least with us moving uh it kind of
opened up their their life which is
which is absolutely awesome do your kids
do kids understand like you and those
snaps do in your podcasts and doing your
streaming do they understand what you
guys are doing
I assume the 16 year old would but the
younger ones uh yeah yeah they
definitely understand us a super-famous
no no and what I have had done what I've
had to do from time to time like certain
streamers and youtubers that they watch
especially one of the twins I'm not
gonna throw out names or anything no
that's that's understandable yeah no I
don't wanna I don't want to blow up his
spot real quick but he
he used to get really energetic playing
games and uses like have like talk
commentary and stuff like that and I had
to tell him I was like dude I understand
what you're doing but you got to
remember the people that you're watching
do that they don't play games like that
all the time they are doing that for the
entertainment of people watching them
they are me they are making money off of
this all right they're using this as a
job and I was like you need to calm down
because you're just really loud in my
ear right now and I can't take it hey
fine is the same thing like their look
their little youtubers like streamers
like in the making and and that's all
well and good but I feel like I need to
tell them that you know there's there's
a difference between how these people
are in front of the camera and how they
are when when they're not recording you
know what I'm saying just let them know
that well do that's something like I
really I really just like it's it's kind
of like how most people that are on some
type of media platform they turned to
almost like celebrities for kids and
it's really weird concept for adults
like us to think that people who are
streaming are celebrities which is kind
of weird but I don't know if you've ever
heard of oh my god dr. o was his name
don't even say disrespect yes yes oh do
you know I don't I don't want your
streams I don't I don't that's something
I think about by the way no I could care
less of his opinion that's my honest
opinion but this what I heard this I was
like it kind of took me back he was
actually streaming right and out of
nowhere you hear pop pop pop and he and
he was like what what's going on and he
goes outside and he found holes of his
house and a couple of ways busted
someone did a drive-by
of his house that is something I cannot
say is more disrespectful like these
people have kids at home they have
families they have pets if you don't
like these people's opinions don't watch
them but like that was something that I
kind of took it and I was just like
these people like with regular
celebrities right there's like an
invisible line between us in regular
celebrities but I may see celebrities
all the time when I live in LA but
there's no one there
we know we're there yeah but when you're
dealing with someone that you watch
every day that's putting content to you
every day they feel like these people
are more tangible right so someone who
gets angry someone who gets angry at
Brad Pitt they're not gonna let you know
and they're like yeah and then I can
spread whatever [ __ ] I'm not gonna
watch these movies anymore but for
YouTube where you'd like this is a
regular person like so we need to you
know the people who think like this are
like you know we need to go fight you
know yeah so not to say that any of that
is condone animal I think take it to
that level and problems if you've heard
of the whole thing with swatting - all
right all members have heard of it I
think it's ridiculous but if you end up
turning into a like a big full-time
content creator you you having to call
your local police department telling
them hey listen this is what I do you
might get a phone call like this it's
fake would you like to come over and
check out my home like I'm sorry I III
think it's a little I think it's diff
do we lose our spot I think we lost them
we lost them so so how you doing
I'm alright like I was just looking at
an email something I ordered in his
point to my old house oh no you know I
think that happens though is it
I don't know you're right you're right
yeah like my my Google Chrome just
crashed real quick okay I think the same
people who put holes in dr. disrespects
house Wow
what rude individuals I know right but
ya know I
the funny thing is I knew where you were
going with that I remember that whole
thing happening and dude it's a it's a
crazy world out there you know I I can
see um I'll let you know I'm 40 years
old I know people say I sound like I'm
12 when I'm doing shows and stuff like
that well I'm 40 years old but I can
still like I said I still have kind of
like that actually to my child so so I
can see kids you know looking at you
know streamers and stuff like that as
you know celebrities I mean look at what
what happened when ninja and and with
fortnight yeah he gets one rapper to go
hang out with him and all of a sudden
man he just blows up like I said the
lotto right time right place right
situation and he blew up but Brian
correct yeah yeah I'll get to that in
one moment I just wanna say Brian Baker
said chrome just crashed just like the
future of stadia and ice I was watching
the math singer and I saw the
information and I said that is a concert
theatre that is a YouTube person that is
a mixer person I'm like it's I'm like
it's gonna be ninja that's a little
really what I said and I said that so
much to my wife and she was just like
yeah because everybody else is like
spewed profanities
there's been in some sarahbooth you know
right right so so I'm gonna ask one more
final question to you 2x by oh well
first I should say L do you have any
more you have any questions before no
[Laughter]
you're gonna get y'all died about your
strike now so if you could live in one
fantasy environment what would it be
like would you love to were live in the
world of destiny would you love to live
in the Wizarding World of Harry Potter
would you love to live in the world of
Mass Effect's the Star Wars what would
you want to do oh it could be any
anything anything well I would I
wouldn't mind keeping a gaming-related
but if you notice every single world
that you talked about is at war or
something like that
right like I would not be in that like I
it would be easy for me to say hallo
right live in the Halo universe but then
if I think about I'm like yo we're in a
power struggle with like right now and a
bunch of like we got Guardians all over
the place like trying to keep the peace
and all this cuz so I don't want to be a
part of that if I'll be a part let's say
a gaming world right I'm gonna have to
kick it back a notch why not be a part
of Viva Pinata oh wow yeah you see what
I'm saying man you go you go out into
the garden and and you you know you're
looking at like new animals coming into
your garden you're trying to get them
into the world you you're building on
these cool houses and stuff like that
everything is beautiful everything hey
Viva Pinata I haven't even thought of
that game amen I see for a while my 16
year old he used to live with his mom
right so the Xbox is where he used to
come over my house on the weekends but
during the week the Xbox was where
me and him would come together uh you
know and talk about life and stuff like
that so Viva Pinata trouble in paradise
and crackdown too
we're like the two games that me and him
played a lot like those are you guys
would bought you browser bond over those
types of days yes exactly exactly which
is why like there's people you know when
crackdown came out right crackdown 3
came out um I was excited for it you
know other people were telling like they
were looking at me cross-eyed like why
and this and that and of course the
online was absolutely broken right the
online multiplayer and stuff like that
but they kept a heart of of the
crackdown franchise together for the
campaign and and even going in and
playing crackdown 3 campaign it brought
me back to the times where I was hanging
out with with my son playing crackdown 2
mm-hmm you know what I'm saying so when
it comes to like when it comes to that
game there's a special place in my heart
for that franchise because you know like
you said I was bonding with my son while
playing these games when we couldn't
hang out together yeah yeah and uh you
know so but yeah like why why not do
like you know cuz when you said that
y'all I automatically went into games
and I thought my absolute my favorite
game all time and this is going to be a
shock to people in the chat it's not
halo uh what is it what is it what is
your favorite game of all time Super
Metroid Super Metroid Super Metroid yes
yes yes that game uh I don't know how
many hours it took up of my childhood I
swear like I I beat that game over and
over and over again and it was just like
the feel of the game when you're able to
get that speed boost and you'll run
across the levels the the bosses at that
period in time the the big kind of like
skeleton boss that came out of the lava
and started marching at you and stuff
like that it just had so
things that that were just so memorable
to me moving forward like I had to put
it it's it's my favorite game all time
second second is a Link to the Past the
Zelda game on the Super Nintendo as well
so a Link to the Past was a classic it
was so good like I mean I sell the game
that came out fantastic now like for me
I didn't own an se a SNES I ended up
playing that game every time I went over
friends houses or you know you go into
the you go into the stores and back in
the day you have all the console setups
and they would always have that and I
would always walked over to it and play
it and like non-stop because it was such
a good game yeah you wouldn't give up
the controller either dude what are you
gonna do in that game in 15 minutes
let's be honest that's nothing nothing
nothing this is crazy it's so good it is
great oh yeah I'd have to put myself
like I want to put myself in a place
where you know it's nice colorful it's
peaceful like I don't want to be at war
I don't want a gun in my hand so I have
to go I have to go Viva Pinata there I
would love to see what the real world
would be with the goose game oh no I
still got to play that like I've seen
I've seen streamers I've seen oh my god
there's literally it's it's a game for
the switch I have not played it I've
only seen people play well it isn't
oh well maybe an epic story I have to
look I'm thinking I don't know why epic
story would have it um
but you'd literally or a goose and you
have achievements to do or I should say
things to do on a checklist and like
literally you would just screw with
people and literally it's like you're a
goose and you are an a-hole
pretty much what it is like like
somebody's like painting a sign or
something like that and one of the
things on your checklist is to steal the
paint from them without them knowing
there's a there's another one where it's
like you have to put like there's a sign
and you knock it over and your
achievement is to have the guy hit his
hand it's hit it's done with a hammer so
when the guy sees it he goes and puts it
back and then he goes to take a hammer
and smack it down and then you go back
like you map him and he got scared and
it smashes his finger and then you see
him he'll hold his finger like it's
literally what the whole game is it's
called Manuel Samuel Manuel Sam you all
manis it's it's been a while yeah it's
like a couple years old but that game
was so much fun I played it with my kid
and like you have to operate the arms in
the legs like with the legs with the
right trigger left trigger mmm arms with
I think the buffers right yeah and it's
like so hard but it's so satisfying
every time you like get anywhere
you know that's like like makes like
crazy Clips like the devil like he's
like a little a white kid okay that's
what I there's a game called heave-ho
from digital to vulvar that we ended up
getting a premiere with when we were in
PAX East and the game is literally you
and your buddies working together to
swing around and get certain things and
it's literally one of the funnest games
to play with your buddies because it's
very similar to that you have to hold
your triggers to move your arms and your
feet and move around maybe you don't
have feet maybe it's just arms but you
have to pretty much link up together and
move is it's pretty it's pretty amazing
it's pretty good yeah you guys you guys
are reminding me
snaps used to well she used to stream on
Twitch a lot I remember she was doing
too soon in hardcore on Twitch for a
while and she used to stream um the game
was I am bread oh yes oh my goodness
that game was so ridiculous but I could
not stop watching her streams and like
how she was like tearing up the
environment just as a piece of bread hi
trying to get toasted it anyway yeah
it's incredible to think about where
games have kind of like evolved from you
know what I'm saying to see what like I
said my very first game was pitfall and
you know it was funny about that
nobody was screaming about graphics or
anything like that for just going in and
having fun playing these games yeah and
I I feel like as the industry gets
bigger I know it makes more money than
the movies and everything like that but
like I got a message out you know for
the gaming community out there don't
don't forget about how you started
playing games like when you started
playing games you weren't thinking about
is this in 4k
what's this gameplay mechanic like oh I
don't like this this feels glitchy you
know what I'm saying who are going in
and you're having fun you were being
taken out of this world and put
somewhere else you know for a couple
hours just having a blast doing
something completely different and I
think I think our community kind of
needs to step back and kind of get back
into that instead of arguing about like
pieces of plastic and and and all that
other nonsense mm-hmm that we've seen
this entire generation it's not the I
I've been I've been around for a long
time seeing the the whole generation war
if you will the Xbox Nintendo
PlayStation you know all of them going
against each other and I don't think
it's ever been this bad and it seems a
little silly brother yeah that the the
funny thing about it is
I I know people are like well you know
it's it's like wrestling or it's like
back in the day with like Nintendo and
Genesis and I was like yeah you know
what the difference between Nintendo and
Genesis era is compared to today's era
we're all grown-ups also social media no
we're all but we're all grown-ups now so
you need to tell me that it's okay to
act like we're 11 and 12 years old like
about like video game consoles you would
figure like the community would mature
over time and it would get beyond that
and not just fall back on it and say
it's okay because when we were kids we
used to do it you know what I'm no I
agree I agree we we have to wrap up
because we are super so what are we why
don't you tell everybody where they can
find you tell them you know what what's
going on what do you have in the near
future
oh so you try and say like a 40 year old
with a comb-over
it's time to get our plugs in right yes
yeah I know it's not one pants leg at a
time and you have to make sure you don't
fall putting in that first pants leg
right yeah no doubt but uh do I keep it
really simple first off on youtube I
have know a small Channel come check it
out we have the next podcast every
Saturday 7:00 p.m. Eastern not only that
you gaming news videos I do stream on
there um you know from time to time
don't I don't necessarily have a
streaming schedule I let people know on
Twitter when I'm going live so if you
want to follow me on Twitter do we just
lose them again thanks Google Chrome
hates him today
oh snap
right all I can think about is that song
every time I think about her name what's
on
thirty something like in the beginning
there's like oh my god why don't you
want to do would you like to tell us
where we can find yeah you can find me
at work no you can find me - Oh 8
everywhere YouTube although like I don't
post there ever a mixer in an on Twitter
and I will hopefully start streaming
next week oh I'm excited right I'm so
glad you're back it's just too crazy I
fully understand that once you get your
schedule kind of down pat and ready to
go yeah then you'll be in business
you'll be good to go yeah I'm pretty oh
great that's the best part all right oh
that's Kim you'd ever cross one light
know you're lucky so lucky so the the
other other table members who are not
here so I'm sorry I just want to make
sure that Xbox you just said he got
kicked from Crum again the other members
that are here that are not here today is
MJ's boss you find him on Twitter he is
the man doing the school like nobody's
business and old-school-style who is he
is on Twitter also he's got a new
YouTube page also I want to tell you to
check out our our lords of gaming dotnet
it is our website that the the iron
Lords podcast guys have created with a
bunch of other content creators to give
people gaming news of things that are
coming on things that are new things
that are interesting and then you have
the iron Lords podcast which is on
Sundays at 11 o'clock sports time which
I like to call football season until it
changes back and then we have our
podcast here
we go live on Monday nights and then it
goes up on Spotify iTunes Google
podcasts I think it is and a whole bunch
of other platforms that you know that I
cannot recall but that comes out on
Wednesdays in the morning you so when
you get up in the morning from from your
sleep you will see it there on your on
your on your everything's if you will
yeah yes all day welcome back sir
dude yeah I thought I thought Google and
Microsoft were getting along now a
little bit better you know they see the
name XY and they just like drop me off
oh my jaw dropping so you would you like
to finish your outro and give a little
plug to to your missus oh definitely
yeah like I said I just keep it simple
it's all ex fought for for eight the
best places follow me on Twitter because
then you'll see when new videos go live
when when we're going live with the next
podcast and uh huge shout out to oh snap
it's no you can follow her on twitter at
girls can gain - - and you definitely
want to go there yo check out I hope she
streams uh destiny - at some point in
time because she was streaming GTA 5 and
dude like talk about cracking up all she
ever did was get into trouble in gta5
like she just she really just went out
to get into trouble
so um her streams are absolutely
incredible so definitely check check out
her streams follow her on Twitter as
well uh I would like to state that she
said shut up gave you the middle finger
via text right so fantastic I mean
exactly so um follow us on table stream
on Twitter I know it's weird but because
we have such a long name it gave me
problems when I tried to create it so I
figured easy for everyone to know we are
table stream I am
now though s nal why do I am on Twitter
and I am also on twitch usually every
day I live in discord so literally if
you ever have a question or something
you want to ask by all means hit me up
in the ILP discord and I will be I'll be
there running within probably within the
next 15 minutes and thank you very much
for Xbox thank you very much for coming
I greatly appreciate it we had a
fantastic time
I didn't even ask half the questions I
wanted to ask you so we'll have to have
you back on to ask you so are we gonna
get a part too are we it may happen it
may happen well we will so we will see
so thank you again everybody have a
fantastic work week I don't like saying
it but it's true so have a great week
and everyone remember to dream big and
keep on gaming have a fantastic one
everybody peace